Five score years ago, I have a dream.
On January 15, 1929, an African-American boy was born to his mother and father.
His name was Michael Luther King, Jr.
As a young boy, Michael grew up in Atlanta, Georgia.
It was a difficult time in the world.
He always found it difficult to play with some of the other boys in town.
Their parents never let poor Michael play with their kids.
He didn't realize it at that time,...
...but the color of his skin would be the cause of many injustices for the rest of his life.
Michael's father took over his father's job as pastor of Ebenezer Baptist Church.
His family had always had an active role in the church since before Michael was born.
At the age of six, Michael and his family traveled to Europe.
While visiting Germany, Michael and his father changed their names to Martin Luther King and Martin Luther King, Jr.
At the age of 15, Martin graduated from high school.
Years later after attending many colleges,...
...Martin moved to Boston where he graduated from Boston University.
While living in Boston, he met and married Coretta Scott.
And two sons and two daughters were born into the family.
While having a happy life at home with his wife and kids,...
...he still felt he had a calling larger than himself.
Over the years, Martin was part of many peace protests.
He preached for peace and for equal rights for not only African-Americans,...
...but for every person in the world.